hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
seeing how it is still Nickelodeon
indeed I think it's time that we look
over another element of Nickelodeon
success the sitcoms or as I like to call
the Nick these are the live-action
comedies and trying to deal with kids
problems the same way primetime
companies try to deal with cell phones
they were creative entertaining and fun
funny well okay maybe not exactly funny
but it's certainly inventive you
couldn't get these shows out of your
head no matter how hard you try God
knows we tried
so rather than mock these shows let's
take a look at how these shows help put
Nickelodeon on the map let's start with
one of their very first Nick comms you
can't do that on television
though technically not made by
Nickelodeon studios you can't do that on
television played a big part in helping
get Nickelodeon it's like death it was a
sketch show like Saturday Night Live or
SC TV that every current character is
and usually a theme that tied them
together for example if the subject was
romance every joke in the show would
have to be about romance and if the
subject was mediocre underwhelming
comedic riding you pretty much have
every single episode ever written watch
this if you don't believe me what is it
you look so happy mom it was love at
first sight I know exactly how you feel
dear it was love at first sight when I
met your father
yeah
the show aired on Nickelodeon
but Gannett starred in America's humble
neighbors to the north Canada which
means you always hear my favorite
mispronunciation devote your book in
remote smoke to Vogue about commencement
how you socially by fret it's about a B
oh you Tina 8000 D stop saying a boat
this is a boat that is a boat
oh boo boo about a boon about that right
every week they would perform in front
of an entire audience of recorded
laughter and they would often have
reoccurring characters and subs like the
firing squad the dungeon and the
dysfunctional family just the upbeat
child-friendly scenarios that we're used
to something you may have noticed is
that all the adults are played by just
two people
Christine look laid and less live did
the majority of the world's jumping from
fat suit defense I have nothing against
this guy but I don't know tell me some
of these jokes seem a little creepy
nowadays like when he plays blip the
arcade repairman
yeah I do man for you is do it okay all
right come on get out of that costume
a-hole
I am madly in love with you Oh God would
you please go out to dinner with me it
was a different time I don't think you
have to worry much though most people
like to know what kind of gender you are
before they start hitting on you and
these kids were often very hard to sort
out one from the other
in fact I often like to play a game at
home I like to call boy or girl all
right let's take a look at our first
subject
short-hair suggests male but the
fluffiness of it suggests female type of
makeup is more masculine but again
though short sleeve a little to the
imagination I'm gonna say boy got it got
it
alright next one long hair close the
ears but kind of a boyish shirt I think
ultimately I'm gonna go with girl
alright got to make it up in the final
round
next subject oh my god I I have no idea
of the long hair of course is feminine
but the lack of any fashion sense is
masculine the urines I guess are a
little girlish but everything else I'm
gonna have to use what my lifelines I'm
going to call a friend hey ciao get over
there wow it would fuck is that I don't
know I wanna do you have a clue good
could be a dude look at the hearing
double look at the glass alright alright
alright I'm gonna say boy it has to be a
boy
it's a girl bullshit I don't know what
is
look it's between Bill Gates and Velma
from Scooby Doo what a ripoff
aside from finding gender of loopholes
the show mostly told a lot of lame jokes
that even most younger kids knew weren't
exactly that funny
hey Vanessa yeah listen what do you
think about computer dating gonna be
pretty boring boring why just one with a
computer you see if they want to make it
like a real locker room they throw on
some real high school problems like hey
Christine
yes Alastair did you hear that Vanessa
got pregnant
Wow I wonder if she's gonna keep it or
abort it it's abortion even legal in
Canada I don't know with our healthcare
anything is possible
hey Doug yes Vanessa is this just a
cheap ripoff of Landon I'm just praying
I have a career after this show that
would have been more realistic actually
the ironic thing is for a show called
you can't do that on television it's
pretty friggin tained especially
considering that most of the things here
they are doing on television I mean
seriously things that you can't do on
television would look like this you see
it's nothing because you can't do it on
television okay for as much as I fan
talk this show it did start a lot of
iconic ideas from him like the idea of
having kids be the star of their own
sketch show the idea that a show with
mostly dialogue won't for kids to them
and of course he's always questioned yep
that's right this was the first show to
introduce that frog diarrhea known as
Nickelodeon slime which dropped out on
the kids every single time they set the
phrase I don't know well that's kind of
random that's like saying every time I
say the word elephant the Burger King
will appear
oh god he's creepy well let's just to
the next show on our Mick counts lineup
quite recent explains it all this show
actually wasn't that bad it wasn't that
funny but did have something kind of
likable about it now granted I didn't
grow up as a girl for long I have a
history but this show did pretty good at
keeping both girls and boys interested
in the program what was it about a
teenage girl and that's about it pretty
much as a teenage girl hey come on
that's not very nice actually it's star
Melissa Joan Hart was really what held
this show together
it's a shame cuz she's always casted in
a bunch of kid ship I really don't think
she was that bad an actress but there
were other characters on the show too
most notably her kid run at Ferguson who
was determined to make her life a living
hell but the longest time I thought he
was just one of those ventriloquist
dummies but then I found out there was a
real actor who played him then there's
her Dobby best friend Sam who for some
reason always enters and leaves through
the window why doesn't that kid ever use
the door that's a legitimate question
why doesn't he ever use the door then
there's her parents who seem rather
comfortable with the fact that their
daughter is a weird psychological trait
whack come on sport is it's time for
dinner
the sooner I just give up on her the
better she spent a lot of her time
chatting it up with Sam talking to the
camera and making video games usually
about indulging her fantasies like any
of us have ever done something like that
make a video game indulging our
fantasies haha alright mine is called
Robo penis muscle ninja I just played in
my spare time by looking at the fashions
you can tell that this was made around
the time when the 80s were trying to die
and the 90s were trying to define
themselves in that they have no original
way of defining themselves but let's be
honest what we all remember from this
show is the theme song that god damned
theme song
what is it with these nineties shows and
having all the lyrics be nothing but
dudes dogs and NAS it's just like
another show that cannot be mentioned
every time I've heard this song I can
never get it out of my head
what will they invent an opening that
and a song get was annoying but not the
least bit memorable like hey dude ah yes
the show that taught us that if you
think your life at home was boring at
least you weren't working on it a
sufferable horse ranch I mean for a show
having to deal with looking after a
ranch in Arizona with horses and
everything this was a really boring show
let me just listen I'll cool the opening
set watch out
man-eating Jackrabbits corn fuck this
sounds cool so tell me what's our first
adventure I'm starting to turn into my
father
Wow so the show takes place on the farm
done dude ranch run by Rick Moranis is
cologne mr. Hearst
Jake or stone
the rest of the characters are teenagers
who deal with real exciting adventures
like who drew this picture of me are we
allowed to ski on the dirt and Who am I
gonna leave in charge while I'm gone
but I'll leave the keys here with
somebody who's it gonna be well I miss
Ernst if I may suggest perhaps you
should choose someone that has proven
herself or himself to be responsible
good leadership skills and excellent
knowledge of horses I think you're both
right
Dani oh no I'm the riding instructor
I'm senior staff all right fine and
it'll be one of you two you decide oh no
you have to decide mystery this time
I'll flip a coin hmm heads
Ted is in charge tails crap funny hats
Bradley please let's just get this over
with
oh hang on it went on a little cheap
fucking Channel seriously it's like all
they do is stand around while they look
at other people having fun hey would
some guys on a boat would it be nice if
we did something like that man that
might be exciting two of us should go
gather up the horses while the other two
go fix the game yeah Danny you and I'll
go fix the gate Ted Brad you guys go get
the horses all right finally getting the
horses I'm riding roping all the good
stuff this'll be fun right that the last
one yep well we got the gate all fixed
great um look guys Brad and I have been
talking and we feel like we kind of owe
you an apology
hi hi that was one horse and we didn't
even see you get it good god you get
more of the Wild West by listening to
Slim Whitman for crying out Wow
I couldn't imagine ever wanting to leave
me neither neither did I especially when
there's just so much stuff to do I
especially love it when they run the end
credits and show stills from the episode
we just watched it seemed to say wow
what an adventure we had huh hey
remember how we used to just stand
around and talk about how we used to
just stand around you don't let me tell
you about we used to just stand around
and talk about how we used
stand around and boom yeah a horse oh
thank God it's gone
alright so hey dude was a bit of a buzz
but one show I'm sure most of you
remember was the short-lived sitcom
salute your shorts
well not exactly hilarious it was a huge
step above some of the other live-action
shows Nick was doing at the time it was
about a cam who had a wild Restless set
of misfits who all like to get into
trouble their counselor was a guy named
Kevin ugly so you can guess what
everybody called it that's right they
called it stupid no they called an ugly
of course as he tries to keep the zombie
kids well under control unfortunately
he's about as effective as Ernest goes
to campus there were a lot of kids on
the show bustling few stood out more
than those there was that moley kid from
Terminator 2 named Bobby what guess
what's supposed to be the wise answer I
tell a ghost on you by hook line and
stinker
I just cut one thanks for sharing donkey
live they seem to have a speech
impediment of all the Looney Tunes I got
everything you asked for
hey what's the difference sufferin
succotash and tele
who seem to push the limits about what
it meant to be a tomboy yeah bet is if
you chicken out to stand up in front of
the whole camp say how much of a wuss
you are and when I win I'll were dressed
for a day oh girl wearing a dress all
the horrid imagery
ah Hey look kid it could be worse you
could be able to hermaphrodite I'm you
can't do that
television who somehow looks more
masculine and feminine clothing how is
that even possible the episode that most
kids remember is the Zeke the plumber in
the zone where a lot of the kids are
convinced that there's a supernatural
ghost named Zeke who's haunting their
dreams Zeke the plumber
that's not very scary no Joe the plumber
that's terrifying they all tried to get
back at Bobby for telling the story by
scaring him in the middle of the night
which apparently doesn't work until
nothing in the world that I'm afraid of
except spiders oh please don't leave me
out of here let's wait till he says yeah
please somebody to help me well at least
until he gives away the portable TV
that's right let him suffer
that's what Jesus would do finally
designed to help him out Bobby wonders
why the other kids came to this rescue
and even knowing what a jerk you are we
still came to the rescue
why because you're my friends no maybe
it's because we wanted to hear you
suffer ah hate vengeance anger truly ugh
has taught these kids great moral values
I just cut one we all have kid we all
have actually Uncas sometimes more
threatening than he is charming I mean
look at how he reacts to this kid for
digging a hole and hitting a water pipe
in this baseball field there is a very
deep hole in the middle of my
eventually this whole Philip and water
and this scum will float to the top
then Bobby putnik you will be mine and
you will know my name is the Lord when I
lay my vengeance upon me you may also
have noticed that salute your shorts
likes to show things three times for
some reason bullshit bullshit bullshit
well not exactly great salute your
shorts did at least try to put some good
jokes together and try to make us laugh
and on the whole it wasn't that bad
it was entertaining enough the
characters were fun and they actually
took advantage of the location but
seriously isn't there an ich komm out
there that was both creative and funny
isn't there a show that has really good
writing funny setups and interesting
characters this is zero now here's a
show that kick-ass The Adventures of
Pete and Pete this show was so strange
and yet so funny at the same time making
all the little things kid noticed seemed
like huge groundbreaking adventures it
was kind of like Seinfeld for kids
taking small unimportant circumstances
and turning them into giant hilarious
events but its brand of strange humor
what Saul is up the show started off as
a series of shorts and when I say short
I need short like 1 to 2 minutes at the
most since they're so short I can just
go ahead and show you an episode give
you an idea just how strange it was tell
me how my brother Pete had gotten a job
as a stockbroker
what Allan was teaching old people how
to air swim hall and me I ended up
cutting the longest stupidest lawn in
the world ok that kind of makes sense
but I began asking myself deep
philosophical questions like two dogs go
to dog heaven
they go to regular heaven well then I
try to blow up passing cars with psychic
energy it only worked once ha
then the heat would get to me and I
started hallucinating about Ellen but
then there she was with a popsicle her
air swimming cap still on why I told her
I still had 6 miles to go I'll just walk
with you a little ways then what the
hell was that it was like a drive-by of
randomness it just came and went and he
was so funny the show was pretty much a
longer and more detailed version of his
shorts which had every bit of that
strange suburban weirdness like the fact
that their mother had a metal plate in
their head that picked up radio waves or
the fact that for some reason young Pete
has a tattoo called the tune-yards arm
or the fact that I don't know they're
both named Pete I mean what the hell
what parent would be so cool it's like
they know the Baldwin brothers Alec and
God knows what Alec Baldwin is too many
there's another character call Artie the
strongest man in the world
okay the strongest man and maybe I'm
missing something but is Artie um
special I never really understood this
character he was kind of like Where's
Waldo as mentally handicapped son I
never really saw the point to it but
then again I guess the whole show is
just about asking the question what's
the point to be honest I would sought
the show was kind of based on the
daydreams that a lot of children have
while sitting through school like I love
the episode where Ellen asked the
question what's the point of algebraic
word problems every teacher who thinks
it over can't give an answer and
ultimately goes crazy or how about the
episode where the kids going to pull
during Adult Swim hours is literally an
act of war it's like when you reach that
point of day dreaming about a real
situation then you suddenly say no that
could never happen
that's where Pete and Pete rules the
credits they push those strange surreal
dreams just far enough to a point where
it's over the top but not unrelatable or
not fun to watch I also like the fact
that the age difference for them in
pretty big so you have the overblown
issues of a teenager as well as the
overblown issues
kiff so that really brought in the
horizons alive as well as the audience
it was one of Nickelodeon's best making
the tiniest of problems seemed like the
most epic of battles and we loved every
minute Nick comms weren't always great
but there was certainly fun and if they
didn't keep trying across the line of
reality and sir reality we never have
gotten shows as awesome as Pete and Pete
so whether it's writing great material
or a load of elephant ship
don't look into his eyes that'll haunt
you Nick Kahn's will always be there to
help us on the creative path I'm the
Nostalgia I remember it so you don't
have to elephant I just cut one